and then again to bring it back to your
other point
those kids those Hood kids they are the
real underground right like you talk
about the Backpackers yeah they had guns
and knives in that backpack and they had
[ __ ] that they stole from the polo store
the underground shout out to the low
heads man the underground kids are the
people that make up the cruise of all of
the major label rappers so while y'all
are praising them and acting like
they're the hardest people in the world
the reason that they're in the position
that they are is because they're backed
by they're getting underground
independent people that are in these
neighborhoods right now you would think
that applies to just one of them no it
applies to all of them right and I feel
like in in my particular situation
um any neighborhood or any City that
I've come in I've always
approach them with such love and respect
that I've gotten nothing but that in
return so whether I'm in Detroit I got
fam out there yeah whether I'm in Miami
and in La I'm home like half my family
moved out here when we came from South
America in 1984 and you know they
married into Mexican families from
Oxnard and also from Inglewood so we've
had our family be here for years right
now we get together we have arguments
about whose food is better peruvians or
Mexicans whose pyramids are nicer ours
but I think that it's nice to have that
kind of camaraderie and I will say this
Kev it's sad for me to see artists come
out here and die or get hurt and raw
because yeah I've oh I've never felt
unwelcome here brother I've never felt
that and maybe it's just because of the
way I move and I don't call it checking
in because I'm not paying people for
protection right I'll come and if some
of the brothers or the essays ask me hey
man we're doing a kids program like uh
for example sick jacking and a hood
Santa and then my homie sleeps the the
artist incredible dude they did this um
they did this workshop for kids where
they brought a bunch of different
neighborhoods together from East Low
some other places to do art workshops I
was a pleasure to join that and I don't
charge people for appearances I'm like
yo man let me just come there whatever I
can do to offer and lend my voice to
this is something that we need you know
at some point somebody's got to be the
adult in the room